my brother from another mother mr. Bryan
Callen
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome we sacrifice a goat to the dogs
ladies and gentlemen Monday morning we
are convinced holes on the [ __ ] up
there and just one Las Vegas yeah but
you and I were talking about like how as
terrible as it is you know I'm not
letting that guy [ __ ] my podcast up and
that's not our job is to keep it going
man you know I'm saying we're so brave
like I'm so pretty relax
I know just do the show I just need to
give out a warning no but it's a
Primorye sobering though I woke up and I
was it's just sobering it's just a
[ __ ] bummer and it makes you feel
heavy and I'm like yeah and so it like
it colors everything you do and it won't
affect you one way yes yes it's like you
know it's hard not to but [ __ ] that
we're gonna do stant we're gonna do the
guy kiss man we're gonna stop man god
damn gonna bust out you wanna go back
over that pre-warning I mean it's a
bummer man what are you gonna do it
sucks
I appreciate if Trump would refer to him
as a terrorist though not white he's a
lone wolf yeah yeah yeah yeah because he
is what I think I know white guy
well CDC kind of right [ __ ] retired as
[ __ ] together unbelievable I don't know
what to make what how to make sense and
then people say I saw the the get in a
NRA right there right well we need to
get rid of silencers if the guns loud or
we're gonna be able to hear it better I
heard the guys well I heard the gun it
was an automatic weapon Kiki Kiki
[ __ ] I talked to my buddy my neighbor
has an arsenal and he said that to get
the piece that you need you can make it
but you got to know your silencer no so
sound suppressors take 12 months against
a license typically from what I you know
he was talking about but to make it
fully ordered this is a fully automatic
weapon tenable yeah 10m okay well the
one he was shooting was automatic where
all which are legal in Las Vegas yeah
but so what to buy the but you can get a
you can get a license for an automatic
weapon it takes a long time it's a whole
elaborate process but but to get just to
first of all to buy one a lot of times
or
30 grand they can be really expensive if
you want to if you have a like ar-15 you
want to make an automatic just to buy I
guess the piece that goes with it he was
telling me that makes it automatically
grant so but some guys can yeah some
guys can afford it or so positive that
he's trying to say like it's hard to get
it's hard to get but not really you know
a guy with money yeah that's so people
though not with a crazy young people
like no it's expensive
that's the argument yeah I know that's
your argument well we obviously have a
gun problem I don't know everyone can't
admit it clearly have a gun problem well
we have a gun problem and I don't think
that guy and I don't want to spend the
whole podcast talking about this I also
think that guy there's no there's no
mental health issues there sometimes you
just have [ __ ] up people man he's a
normal dude no one well his if we I
guess his dad was a former bank robber
you know I'm saying saying who knows
like who know like somebody was like gum
I remember this this my friend was
talking about there was a guy in Europe
who is killing couples and removing
their genitals and yeah and they find
two couples dead and they'd find their
and I guess they finally caught him and
he had all these jars with their job no
it's a long time ago and I said to my
buddy I go why like I go I was looked at
I go why was he doing it my buddy goes
oh okay see his mom left when he was 9
and also is that what the [ __ ] do you
mean why there's no why well you know
like he's a nice there's no ants but
also you I don't think you just chalk it
up to his childhood like no I have a lot
of friends that tear up yours and
they're awesome
right to know me you know the shot yeah
you mean women they beat 0 that's right
they go the opposite way they're
actually great sometimes in life the the
hard thing to accept is that there's no
why that you don't have an answer that
you can figure out everything you want
about his profile and it's it that what
doing what he did makes no sense doing
what he did is terrible do any what hey
this does sober your day and ruin your
day maybe ok and and that's just kind of
how it is sometimes it just sucks right
people suck we all want [ __ ] simple
[ __ ] we all want an answer though just
chalk it up gothic I [ __ ] sucks or
just life is like full of like I think
that Hugh
beings want all this certainty and it's
totally natural to what safety I think
that somebody said that the thing that
human beings naturally want as we've
evolved this security is the one thing
we we just crave like we can't get
enough of people yeah abundance security
just because the majority yeah I feel
safe yeah like I don't feel safe when I
go do uh like that's the reason I don't
own a lot of concerts I don't go to a
lot of live events I don't enjoy them
like no I don't it's stressful because
I'm afraid well I decide it saying that
I'm afraid there's like a lot going on
even if there isn't this schmuck there
they know it's not that and they're like
you're letting them win I know I feel
like this inside me I've been it's just
actually just so much going on it's just
a lot like there's so much that could go
wrong when it's not that I'm like [ __ ]
from Along Came Polly Ben Stiller like a
risk an ally I just know when I was when
I was a young man probably my teens I
camera in there was a the soccer fans in
England there was an event where like
they were there and a fight broke out
between two opposing sides and people
got crushed in the Stampede and got
crushed against the fence and I was like
well there it is yeah like I never
forgot that I'm risk-adverse you know
but listen at the same time it doesn't
mean you don't go out to a [ __ ]
concert and it's no it's I enjoy
yourself I'm just I'd rather watch at
home and you know me people are gonna
Stampede my legs there open fire there
yeah I can guarantee is zero zero
yeah was like in college you know we'd
win a big game in the fans of Russia
field I darted for the locker room it
always scared me yeah [ __ ] yes meanwhile
having some video having said all that a
and you could get cancer and you can get
hit by cars that's that I can't control
that that's right I can yeah yeah well
I'm reading people ask me what to read
all the time I'm reading up I sent you
suggestin sapiens no yeah amazing book
by you how Harare amazing book about
like sort of like a history of humankind
and one of the things that he's talking
about later on the book is like what we
can expect from technology if you talk
to computer scientists and stuff so
they're coming up with a way for our
brains because our brains create
electrical signals we already have this
guy named I think his name is Jesse
Sullivan he had
as he lost both his arms he's an
electrician he lost both his arms of the
shoulder like some [ __ ] freak
accident which I don't know how the [ __ ]
that happened both his arm both his arms
at the shoulders like what what were you
doing you like what you do will you a is
that a great white Cadiz you know I
don't know what happened stress
something really weird by the way I love
that Instagram you posted oh the guy
getting bit by the tiger I mean the lion
thoughts a professional rugby players
the guys coach took him took the team up
for a game and he's all like this
[ __ ] camera hey bro which bright Dame
emergency room or something missing few
games yeah of course but but I don't
have that well I guess I did put that
crocodile in Costa Rica let's see I
don't have that in me but at least you
were like at least you were like just
putting the top heat up to spin all the
way around and [ __ ] not a good idea
but with a line I was like oh [ __ ]
but also I'm not petting he was like oh
yeah you never do that yeah but but so
so he's talking about how we now have so
this guy who has Bionic arms he can move
his arms by thinking they have
electrodes in his head and he can
actually move the Bionic arms to grab
stuff you bring bring it up Jesse
Sullivan Bionic arms and he can move his
arms just by thing also bring up cage
from Mortal Kombat yeah it's kind of
incredible right and so as we are
learning how to create interfaces
electrical interfaces our computers are
gonna be able to read our brains and we
will be able to read the computer but
like we'll communicate with brains but
that raises all kinds of [ __ ] crazy
questions because we might be able to
interface with other brains we might be
able to interface with all different
kinds of brains and the question becomes
like as we create this neural net as we
kind of like as your experience some of
your experiences might be sudden look at
this guy look at this guy look at this
he's thinking his arm he's thinking his
arm come on he's opening his hands I
mean are you [ __ ] kidding me right
now that's the craziest [ __ ] in the
world we are we are truly coming up with
that you know we got a ways to go
we got a ways to go yeah I'll take my
organic organic arm but I'll take
homeboys arm got Ben
by that Tigershark that looked all sweet
that's barely moved that stiff hand [ __ ]
hasn't no good two-hand job but yes yeah
that's a tough thing but at least he can
think it on oh that's cool
yeah and and but as I'm able to [ __ ]
download your memories and your like
your experiences like they really have
homie and I can do that with a woman and
I can do that with anybody all the
sudden it becomes like the idea of of
like experiencing what a woman thinks
about is not going to be a mystery
anymore then it throws into question the
notions of gender then it could then
then he was talking about the [ __ ]
thing that's computer scientists really
worry about talking about things you
can't control and stuff where the
computer does you humans not not only
that we're just gonna kill how about
this so sometimes there's a computer
well there's a computer virus
okay no problem shut your computer down
we'll get it we'll get a fit and what
happens is you send a virus out there to
kill that virus
well that virus like like might be able
to mutate on its own once it mutates or
it so to keep keep the other viruses
that are coming after it or the you know
it mutates on its own it keeps mutating
on its own and all of a sudden you've
got like literally all these self
mutating and self-evolving viruses in in
the [ __ ] cyberspace and now what are
we gonna do well now you're [ __ ] now
now like your computer shutdown or now
your computer taking over all the
computers are taken away by these we
just unplug them I don't know so we just
um pull hold on your old iPhones you
bastard we just go zoom this is why I'm
not on the cloud I'm afraid of it with
you guys don't download my dick pics
download the dude knows that I sell a
lot of my dick my shaft pics yellow
anyway there's a lot of [ __ ] that we
just don't have control over it that's
coming I just feel that I guess that's
what I'm saying it's coming they got
they got [ __ ] how about this they got
in in the military right now they are
working on ways to read your brain ways
to scan your brain so that you say I was
not in that bank that you'd they robbed
they go oh that's interesting because
it's showing up that you've seen that
Bank because we have the pattern we
showed you a picture of the
awesome and you're recognized awesome I
don't know if I want but the computer is
reading my my mind who I don't want I
want my private thoughts you're a
compulsive liar that's hey people are
honest you don't know that we were
honestly kidding what are you reading my
mind right now
I think you had heard a lot of people's
feelings though leave Watson I don't
know don't want I'm getting the job
because I'm qualified
what the [ __ ] it just shows what it is
oh what you're thinking it just shows
this old dude just think you're gonna I
mean that a lot of people's feeling
it'll also it's also you don't want you
know you don't want a government agency
being able to read your [ __ ] mind I I
don't feel comfortable that cuz I don't
know who's in charge of the government
changes Yeti Bravo I would like it if
they had if it helps like solve murders
and stuff like that in crime and some
like that which it could oh yeah 100%
cut that it's good and bad like good
this is a thing with technology you know
how much you know technology just way
more good than bad but for whatever
reason humans gravitate towards the
negative well that's awesome a guy is
throwing arms we're watching that move
how do % technology's gonna free us 100%
there is a dark side of technology that
a lot of people that are in at the
cutting edge of this are genuinely
afraid of because they're not gonna go
with control for sure yeah
then it'll take over and once it takes
over I'm gonna be dead so I'm like learn
cutting it out figure it out figure it
out
yeah yeah I don't know if your house
Philadelphia maze god damnit I was
Philly you know you done with the
computer yeah I'm all set myself how
look man Philly was amazing sold out
every show thank you very much and I
love I love that town I love helium
Billy it's a great I had a great time
and you know good food yeah I'm a
creature of habit though I needed this
one place melodramas if it's good so far
the place you told me that I'll enjoy I
think across from helium ah yes that's
it yeah the pasta yes it had like
Lobster yes but yeah it's [ __ ] good
at much rachana the police isn't so good
bring your own wine I brought my own
wine I got no I don't need to go
anywhere else right you know what yeah
how about Stevie Stevie
blue eyes Stevie will get will do an
airbnb and he'll this is Stevie he goes
right to the supermarket he'll buy
himself a gang of sweet potatoes a gang
of white rice chicken breasts got his
asparagus and some salad you just eat at
home
some niño and he gets an innie cooked
with coconut oil and I'm telling you
right now that guy will eat five meals a
day that's what he eats and the last
meal of day I mean it's like 12:00 it's
1:00 2:00 in the morning
he's putting down chicken and rice
anyway sleeps till about well you'll get
it you'll get a solid 11 hours of sleep
in you stays a little roll out yeah
it'll get himself some coffee it's
prison schedule go go workout for go
body bill he's an institutionalized
three hours your body's institutionalize
three hours looks good he's in some time
to do his thing I mean I'm like you want
to go eat he goes yeah I'm good got my
sweet potatoes he's clean the other
thing maybe just doesn't want to hang
out you that much well that's probably
it could be that there's some of that uh
when you're around somebody yeah you're
like now I'm good man yeah guys are like
that like what are we gonna do talk more
I just have just you how about daliyah I
[ __ ] I forgot him but Julius Ennis is
sure it's the so free country [ __ ]
all the rats a lot they sold a ton of
them off the show anyways it's a freak
conscious for you
I was running yesterday wearing that
shirt and because the times are going
through with the flag I get so many
weird looks man really yeah I st. Chris
the thing I'm like dude your shirt I've
never got so many if I didn't look like
a [ __ ] cereal why we don't know it
people I think I don't know today they
don't know what they say yeah I think
they think it's disrespectful recons
yeah and everyone's just staring at me
like what the [ __ ] man I'm wearing mine
and there's some military guys there
work it like some you know gnarly
Doozers kept stare at me I felt like
going up to me explaining like this is
he's a comic and it's it's a free
country it's free concert become friends
with friends it's very kind
yeah it's weird but I told I said your
thing brother strigas Todd I'd even
think about it but don't worry about
your fan base won't realize [ __ ]
don't worry about it man you know they
won't I finally saw it dude I like that
movie have you seen the new one yes I
really liked it I found it very moving I
thought it was alright I thought it was
like game I thought it was kind of a
shady long episode of stranger things I
know now and I am the biggest it fan of
all time
I love I love that I thought the clown
was great
I thought the how they showed him more I
thought Pennywise was cool but I didn't
like I thought it'd been more scary if
they didn't make him so like gimmicky
like the way he opened his mouth and
like I thought it'd be better just like
a straight murder yeah I didn't think of
it as a horror movie I thought of it as
a like a classic prototypical movie of
young young kids who learn how to be
like heroes like they they face their
fears yeah that's what I liked about
yeah I don't like I never I didn't get
stranger things how dare you I didn't
think we got it yeah well the safe the
same exact same but I felt it was better
it's good it's you know it's the most
successful horror movie of all time and
they already have you know because in
the originals part 1 part 2 merrily
you'd rent it you get double DHS's yeah
so part twos already they're already in
the works then have a prequel where they
talked about how penny wise became penny
wise really you see the actor the plays
penny wise yeah good-looking kid young
the I thought it's cool how much they
showed the clown like you know
originally they didn't show him a lot
they should I never saw the original you
never saw the reads oh wow did you read
the book no you don't think that book is
an effect but it's Steven I tried it and
got it brought to school my tea I think
I was in fifth grade my teachers like
what are you doing Stephen King and his
imagination that's like just incredible
man Shawshank Redemption he wrote The
Shining he wrote here Rachel Jenny sure
did Steve sure did look that up chin
Cena King real Shawshank Redemption did
I don't think I should bring up what
Stephen King has wrote so we can Oh put
Stephen King Shawshank for me okay are
you sure B uh-huh sure he wrote anybody
mm-hmm yeah novella by Stephen King
Jesus God do you have no idea what
genius bro he's a [ __ ] I thought he
just lived in horror oh no sir please
bring up the the take a look at what
he's written because you'll be amazed at
how many things you've seen that we're
amazing just like the utmost of it I
know I don't think Shawshank surprised
the [ __ ] out of me but um The Shining
that he wrote he didn't remember write
about the shining he doesn't remember he
doesn't remember
Cujo he was so drunk The Shining it
carry misery
remember misery hell yeah goddamn hold
on the stand the Green Mile
the dead zone Cujo damn he wrote cream
miles yes I mean come on
needful things was good amidst the myth
needful things was [ __ ] really good I
remember that let's not let's not along
well this was Christine The Talisman
Lindsay story Pet Sematary I never saw
all pets there's good the Tommyknockers
keep going the firestarter hero fires
her night shift is that the night shift
I'm thinking about no I don't you love
survival hearts in Atlantis that's a
great one on writing I read I didn't see
that Dolores Claiborne [ __ ] Dolores
Claiborne the notebook this is hey you
don't that's not true you see you see
notebook the running mate not the
running mailer think of no he's done a
shitload of book no the right he did
that is the running man I think that's
the one that's not the one is that
thinking that's the one I believe before
say yes and then Colin Farrell read it
he's believing he's a genius he's a
[ __ ] genius dude he's a
strange-looking fellow Haney he's got a
long gap between where his nose in the
end of his lip is you know who he looks
like
Felder the fighter yeah oh my god you
look like a grown Feldick holy crap oh
you know what the live head that's
interesting he looks
hold up identical you know that Paul
Paul Paul Felder was a theater major yes
really smart guy I had a really good
talk with him really very nice Oh what I
thought he'd be they look very similar
yes I like that guy
doing pretty well did his last fun thing
he did uh he's been doing commentating
he has yes smart guy he's been doing
well yeah um you like to Stephen King
though I wonder if the end of someone
else did that already I forget what the
entire just um they do look very similar
though well they have what you're
noticing is a law a large gap between
his nose and his mouth that's what Paul
has they look very he looks like his dad
yes looks like is dead
yes similar mouth how about [ __ ] I
don't know if its current event but you
have no died the the great Hugh Hefner
who lived in a robe and smoked a pipe
and had sex with the best-looking women
of all time all the way up until he died
oh please what killed her so my [ __ ] is
at half-mast today my [ __ ] is okay so is
my zipper because that my balls are my
[ __ ] at half-mast my zippers at
half-mast and I got and I Bulldog my
nuts for the day
you should Bulldog your nuts and I'm
gonna take a bunch of Viagra and have
sex
I'll tell you what's interesting about
this too is a lot of people like shaming
him like finally what he did to women
and what he did [ __ ] off you [ __ ] do you
see but uh the grave next to Marilyn
Monroe and they're trying to avoid him
being buried there because he released
Marilyn's pictures without her consent
and mouth you know I don't know that you
said that's true
it's true but still it also made her a
superstar anyways but you know what he
said of course I would be babe next the
hottest blonde of all time I've always
loved once it's almost been an attorney
with Malin Monroe they never met you got
a lotta met the guy he just he did what
he wanted how I saw a documentary on
Hugh Hefner okay I was very much you
have no laid to rest let's move so did
happen yeah they're trying to stop it
from happening I saw a really good
documentary on a very smart guy really
interesting he just was honest about
what he liked and you know what he was
like I'm gonna I want to be around the
best-looking women of all time
men women that'll bring you to your
knees and I'm and I wanna have sex with
him okay mm-mom right I'm sign me up
so now
so remember he sold the Playboy Mansion
I think or someone to dig some but he
want like hundred fifty million two
million they got it what history but the
the deal was is the guy couldn't
completely take over the property until
Hugh passed away he was still living on
the property so now have you been there
yes
yeah me too it's all it's all we think I
wish I'd seen more of it I need to know
it's how many people told ya so you
think yeah it's a real shame though the
ultimate Wow he's kind of a last of
dying breed right I mean Dan Bilzerian
would be like the poor man's version of
that right oh there's a lot of guys no
but a guy who oh I'm saying a guy who
he's like I guess the last we're what's
so visible right it's no there's a lot
of guys out there though like that but
when you think about the Playboy Mansion
you think of those women and you think
of one area and a guy who literally
lives with these the hottest girls who
walk around naked and does what he wants
in a robe that that's that's that would
be right now in today's world we'd all
be like oh you know like he'd get a lot
of heat for her to be a lot of but I
think we were out there I feel like he's
he's the last of that and by the way it
was a magazine magazines nobody I was
doing I was doing a radio John de bellas
show in Philly Philly and the kid who
was 30 had never we were talking about
Playboy and Hugh Hefner and the kid was
30 had never actually seen the
magazine's he'd only seen it digitally
online and when you got a Playboy
magazine with those glossy pics it was
like [ __ ] like as a kid you were like
what up I'm too young for that too but I
I saw the magazine but then Maxim did
that whilst he not butt-naked but max
Asher
kind of took it from there and then
there's other magazine Penthouse and
Hoss part where the to hustling hustling
was that was too much
that was our boy Larry Flynt yeah too
much Bob Guccione he was penthouse you
know Bob Guccione huh so Bob bring Bob
Guccione up [ __ ] awesome he was early
it was a boss to though Larry fun was a
boss before johnny was a guy look at it
look at him he was
he was a really good photographer and an
Italian he looks like mr. Fudd now fast
I would not bring any girl I care about
yeah you can't keep going there he'll
live I think he died I think Bob
Guccione died but he was and I feel he
died the cheering erected there is he
had plastic surgery look at his face so
if a vain man a vain man it's like a
bloodhound there you can't get plastic
surgery you can't do that you can't wear
a wig you can't do it's like Stephen
King with the Dutch with you you just
yeah you gotta you gotta age gracefully
you cannot plastic surgery doesn't work
but he was great back in the day his
shirts open house look at them oh and he
would take it he would be even though he
owned the magazine he would take the
pictures I feel like with the Hugh
Hefner you know how he was a man of
power you know a power position Elsie
had multiple women he's like loud and
proud about it that still goes on today
especially with men in power I mean Todd
Todd Oh God horse like yeah you know
even on narcos they'd a touch a little
bit on it but like one of the head guys
you know in the Cali cartel had three
wives what people in power it's just
like you're not just gonna drive the
same Rolls Royce every day when I go to
fighting events so if you go to a boxing
event if you go to a high-profile UFC
event you see powerful men athletes
businessmen with these girls that are
just like like chew toys like just like
you're just like hot that is a harsh
well I'm just sorry but that's what it
looks like really I like me to be the
biggest in the world
no I'm saying these girls are
professional hot girls they're there
it's such an such an interesting like
you're the alpha male and you have the
girl you wanted in high school and here
it is and she's just huge fake tits and
just me the waist ass gauge it's just
it's just so it's almost like it's
almost like I always feel like it's a
it's the equivalent of like I Drive a
Ferrari and I got this I got this girl
yeah I but also I think you know the
guys in that you guys empower the guys
that got those girls didn't establish or
kind of how I put this they're not the
guys who created the norm
that everyone lives by today that makes
sense well that makes sense well it
certainly does sir it certainly does and
I want you to know that I know exactly
what you're talking about
yeah like I feel guy with look when he
would warm look in what you're saying is
that what you're saying is that if might
you have the way they wanted to they'd
have that group like that B I know what
happened that'd be the norm yeah that
that well that's what happens you get a
lot of money would not be no no I mean
the dead that's right I mean so that's
that's what I was trying to say is that
when you see these really powerful men
you're like I think you're married but
that those two professionals you know
like you see these you're like oh you
know I think I think I read that you
were I'm sure you guys just friends
right you know yeah like that I assume
yeah well ambition cuts all the way
across right are you a piece so hard I
should see what happens start talking
about sex and girls and his bladder
starts to explode well you're back from
draining your dong yeah I'm on you know
you're on e come on e okay like this and
e come on oh man dude you're all why you
smiling so hard peeing does feel nice
though people think I have a problem
like Joe was like do you realize you go
to the bathroom all the time hydrate you
drink all the time yeah non-stop always
kind of watering yeah non-stop
little Campari show that night like that
my nights well if I'm if I don't I'm on
a night damn I don't sit on window
anymore because if I sit by the window
my mind will play tricks I'm like I
gotta pee even though I don't if you're
by the window yeah I'm like I'm probably
not to get up pretty soon that's weird
yeah and then I make people get a window
on the plane yeah Oh weird cuz you're
gonna sneak by oh you're saying you
don't want to be a nuisance
yeah excuse me but it's tough sales if I
big deal unless y'all a boy Philly took
forever though coming back from Elliot
from Philly to LA cuz the tail winds you
go there the tail winds hits you see you
you I thought it's faster back well no
on the way back it's like it was five
hours and you know six hours [ __ ] off
and then you're sitting on a plane for
long time you're on a plane for seven
hours
[ __ ] you that planes just art I hate him
I don't do well they just are not
healthy yeah they're not I don't do how
about having ranan in a while I've just
been doing my work out that box and burn
with Glenn I was like you know what my
knee feels all right I wouldn't saw that
therapist help my knee I'm all right
started writing yesterday that's good
for 6:00 I'm like you know what I think
I'm fully recovered I'm going for a long
old job now one for that long jog well
click click later in the knee see I'm
glad to hear that only because I like
that I'm not the only idiot so I'm 50
and I hurt my back why I decided you
know Brian gonna box then play tennis
and then just practice little golfing
just move around my daddy wrestled with
me well no no it wasn't even that my
back was like feels little it's tight I
can't figure it out you know what I'll
do a box with Wayne again dad it under
that and let me twist real hard yeah
I'll keep twisting real hard oh there it
is I feel that little tiny like a little
like you try to ignore it you're like
I'm gonna ignore them but it's just like
that well my back seizes the [ __ ] up I
can't really lift my left leg to tie my
shoe I'm like oh something's going on
here
yeah then I let it just whatever I let
it relax I let it starts getting better
I'm like you know what it's a little
better there's nothing better
it's nothing you want to do more when
your back starts to feel a little better
than warming up a little and since I'm
feeling so good right now
I'm gonna do some dead lifting because
I've earned it that's smart that's just
stupid be back straight keep it back so
I'm keeping the back straight no problem
I'm back I'm dead lifting not a lot I'm
not you I'm dead lifting maybe 150 or
something just to warm it up well as I
did lifts as I'm leaving little as I'm
putting it down my wife walks in to the
garage startles me a little bit yeah my
back goes geek and I just around I got
[ __ ] your back yep and now today it's
better is it better yes to be flying the
plane today I'm good sitting for this
particular thing for whatever reason
helps me walking cousin Eastside [ __ ]
with me for whatever reason when Julia
was here time he tried to got about a
hundred thousand views
act up a little bit well we haven't
scratched fathers grafton yeah well it
bothers me that I was delicate with you
cuz I didn't blow my neck I let you snap
it down and that's why you got me there
right next time I bow my neck
oh we tango a little bit more face to
face why did I pull your hood over your
head like a hockey moving [ __ ] pluck
your duck tails don't why do you have
those duck tails listen man cuz I'm a
man bro let's want that waxed off and
film it so my wife doesn't want me to
take that area off why why she she likes
it or something weird women we don't
know what you know I should do that why
she wants to stay ugly that's right I
see this all the time now I like your
hair
don't take propecia oh no no you don't
have bags in here I just walk around
what your gray oh yeah what's your gray
so I keep your teeth yellow and crooked
do you know what make your teeth yellow
and crooked we're the same thing every
day
we're business socks with those athletic
shoes do that yeah I like that that's
eternal he never does it or anything but
that yeah you know why uh-huh bring you
down uh-huh
she she doesn't want you pika conversely
they've done so I think we should do
what I think we should go get some [ __ ]
waxed wax me up a little bit wax us both
up I met a girl like Dana swag I met a
girl this weekend who's an aesthetician
aesthetician aesthetician whatever she
does so patients up yeah yeah and I did
not know her she came to the show we
were all hanging out it's a group of us
and she goes I said what do you do said
I'm an esthetician I said oh cool she
goes you ever have your [ __ ] waxed
and right off the bat yep and I went I
went we got a free color I know sure
haven't as she goes you haven't I go no
I haven't you to see you got a hairy ass
I go well I manicure a little bit she
goes you got a hairy ass like she would
even here she goes I go I should just
come on by I go you're 28 I'm not doing
that I don't know you what are you gonna
do spread my peach no you will no you
gotta hold your legs you've done it no I
caught the lady about it I thought about
doing it yeah just to clean up sure I
wouldn't mind but I don't know I don't
know you man
I had Joe do it cuz Joe was like I was
like you know I'm embarrassed to do it
lady I don't know I'm not gonna [ __ ]
stripper
my [ __ ] for this lady liquor you know
put my legs I just kidding hold the
balls up no I don't know so I had Jojo
bought a home kit yeah and I was like
now if you're gonna do this and I was
like let's just start with a patch like
I'm inside of my thigh here I'm not here
dude but let's just start there see how
tissue geo saw me my mom do this all the
time it's not that bad oh we [ __ ] she
was becoming [ __ ] tat dude you have
like yeah you're right cuz this doesn't
hurt his best I'll just put the wax
there was a guy she put that patch there
it was Johnny you're peeling a peach
over the one side so I got my dick in my
hand I say that a three-piece yeah you
got your three-piece three-piece bazooka
to the side Haven overdose a bazooka
either and then it's here yeah it's all
there and then she puts the wax puts the
yeah you got your little nub right there
in your poem I got I got the dead
vulture like beside you you got the baby
not just pulling the baby bird on his
wings also known as my nut you got that
sad baby bird over there yeah it's like
your baby vultures like yeah yeah
puts that wax the blue wax there God
puts the tape I'm like that's not to be
that's kind of warm and she goes ready
one two three
hey cute never again I will never ever
do that again salute that was the worst
pain I lutely want to put that on my
rump roast yeah [ __ ] off there has to be
easier way to get this done I don't know
what to do I'll shave it down that's my
barber fade that hey can you give me a
ball taper fade on my [ __ ] how much
is that how much is that how much is to
get the Philly fade I'm thick take us
now make a straight razor to my rum how
much is it to get that Philly fade on my
nuts huge [ __ ] if it's sixteen for the
head how much for my [ __ ] for my
[ __ ]
give me a high-top fade on my [ __ ]
conversely by the way speaking of Elbaz
men they say men a lot of men will
fatten their wives up so that they don't
cheat on them so that's a I've read that
many times where men will
well guys always think try control them
like everyone wins I never understood
that me neither I've always been like
[ __ ] do your thing in shape look at
her that's right [ __ ] right look at her
that's right why would you wanna be seen
with the
out of shape she's dressed in the trash
I never understood that's insecurity on
the green I think you're worried she's
gonna watch this dress - she's really
Australia laughs you take care you [ __ ]
it apparently this works on both sides
like there Dave like you said women want
they don't want yeah your wife's doing
it to you the doc tell hey look at me
right now yeah you know in the world
like to think that sexy there's not some
lady I don't have that much hair on my
back
you have spots and you have that patch I
had a biopsy on my back don't make fun
of me of spots and you get that big
patch of here it's little me here
there's another girl in Russian thing
good my back was put on that video you
can see my lats your wife's trying to
bring you down bro right it's like when
you tell her to keep wearing that hat
yeah it's true I worked out today I was
looking in the mirror not good hold a
lot of water in my face ate too many
Cheetos last night you say that but
that's just your face bro yeah like you
all the time I'm like what's wrong with
that guy ate this I drank this Hey look
at me yeah it's your [ __ ] face you're
50 hey man
I'm the same way just my face man we men
not really bloated
I want delious in this picture he's
actually in good shape
in this sense picture he goes good
what'd he say all pumped you like just
got done right it's a picture in front
of his house with his shirt off he looks
good last night he sent me this picture
he looked really good last night at 1:00
in the morning
this [ __ ] I get I get this picture
here he sends me a picture of his leg
just his [ __ ] leg you know people
won't be able to see this piece of this
ain't gonna work on a podcast yeah yeah
does that make famous like well we're
having a nice time to decide to do that
we can bring this up no he can't
yeah we can but it's also just a picture
his leg
I believe funnier on that camera than my
I just forgot yeah but he's the what
thing I was talking about when he sent
us pictures of him working out ways in
shape he looks good he looks really good
got some chest on him and he's a big guy
he actually he's not small enough muscle
goes on you know he's full muscle
do you want a fleet ya know he does look
good yeah he does get some current
events should hold up what you guys do
this weekend and Jake it on that might
go oh I forgot there's live on its again
I like your pashmina there's something
cool about wearing like like I like just
I mean that's a blanket it's a blanket
with holes in it I'm gonna wear I'm
gonna start wearing a blanket I'm gonna
start walking around with a blank would
you do a little MJ homework homework I
have to make a video of how to sell
brick so just doing present what happens
you have to make a video on what how to
sell a brick how to sell one game how
what cocaine's a brick yeah to build a
house ya know just like a brick in
general so they wanted to show you to
see like how good of a Salesman you are
like I can wolf of wallstreet like sell
this open-celled brick so making a video
tonight so if you want to see it what's
your major business and marketing yeah
that's my just trying to make something
simple make it difficult yeah and then
have you seen Annabelle yes okay
Annabelle was way better than it my way
scary dolls and scare some what I've
seen like that yeah they all connect so
the director of the conjuring and
Annabelle all of them connecting the
stories and then they make their own
stand off two of the nurse who's in all
the scary movies and the nuts the nun -
so scary
Annabelle scariest [ __ ] yeah legit scary
movie I've seen lights off lights out
lights out yeah it's actually based on a
little short film have you seen the
short no it's actually really cool is
what I said about the veteran who's
blind what we're saying them James don't
a scary movie about notes is this demon
that if the lights are on like it
disappears it's a whole lot to get it
yeah you're seeing it don't breathe
that's more of suspense yeah they're
both based on choice I'm pretty sure I
think don't breed this from like some
filmmaker that made a minute low-budget
like short film wait but Annabelle's
been out for a while yeah I don't like
to go when there's no one in the
theaters so I can like no stepladders um
last week in Muncie it was
though yeah and that's I don't really do
much would you do 10 I feel like you are
like there's you have a secret life
yeah me too I feel like this weekend was
thoughts Thursday I went dancing yeah I
saw some foster Thomas that's what
happens I probably means nothing to you
guys logic Thomas's what boombox cartel
how did you know what the house is yoga
invite me he's what is he it's just some
dubstep kind of music I don't know it's
like going out in like over a month
sounds like I went out dancing Thomas to
this big mosh pits at a club hold up you
went to a mosh pit yeah play a song for
us gin that's what they look like damn
are they popular MJ they're pretty
popular yeah it's like EDM so when we
say you went out there you danced this
music I was there this year
I have bartend for insomnia
[Music]
this is them they have the best
fireworks show EDC I know this firework
show no it's more like head banger
though you put on the song mosh pit yeah
don't put go put on from note one that
don't do they have a music video chin
what was it called lost mosh mosh pit so
weird doesn't it isn't like my music of
choice but it's fun to go out dusablon
yeah exploit this is so very this is
what you dance too
oh this is me show me how you dance all
right well let's hear it first uh-oh
trigger seizures did you stop warning it
says yeah epilepsy it will trigger
seizures B well you gotta ask
make that ass clap for safety you know
wait for the beat to drop too though
don't do too much
yeah don't do too much to the beat drops
up just chillin it's about to drop e3
war Brian Taylor beat well I feel like
you're a little off
I feel like you're not hearing the beat
though what I feel like you're too happy
for a mosh pit theme okay will this turn
into Magic Mike what was your tongue out
like that is it usually wrap like this
if there's just a white-hot it's a white
dude he's the DJ used to be a group of
two people and now I think he's just
doing his own thing I'm not mad at it
I can't drive to this music and chill
but he and I in cocaine this music I
could do a shitload of drugs in life I
just get high and wet yeah there's some
I'm like I was in the VIP so I was just
looking down everyone and then we went
out to the mosh pit people like press
down and offer each other it's kind of
not exactly my thing yeah mom I haven't
gone out in a while so that my friends
invited me out and so that was my thing
and I feel super lame
why that's cool that's what you should
be doing yes yeah Wow dude how would I
mean that's it for you that must look
like like the Bionicle arms you know
like for me that's crazy
yeah like I'm not I've never heard of
that bad for you that is kind of techno
right I mean it's it's like a techno
hip-hop like EDM has like over a hundred
subgenres so there's like drum and bass
to dubstep too like house to hardstyle
honestly like oh when I was 22 I went
that was in San Francisco and I'd never
done Molly before or E and I did ecstasy
and those back in the day though do that
oh my god and I was dancing and I was
doing and I was doing
and there was no [ __ ] warehouse not
hungry no dude I'm hungry
I was like this I was like first of all
I I'm the best dancer of all time
second of all I'm so [ __ ] cool like
this I go piece and he gave me a piece
back and I go oh no I was with my girl
but I hug the dude I was like god I love
you I love everybody I love you I love
my girl yeah you're my mate she goes I'm
your Michigan marry dude we were kissing
weird and then I had to step over a rope
I couldn't and she helped me and then we
went back and we made love and I came
for hours hours and hours right like I
made love like never before and then
when I had my my I came I can't him and
it was the greatest thing Laurie all
times like a unicorn a purse snatchers
day
they're depressed I got ya heavy lies
the crown because do that oh yeah I was
down odds like yeah you like that you
like that just wait for it got my nice
sore throat yeah I know
nice let's go work though huh sure sure
it's but greatest feeling of all time it
was nice where he's feeling of all time
god I could not believe you want some
right now Jim would you do just [ __ ]
didn't do you didn't Raven Texas you did
[ __ ] getting a mosh pit
you didn't come on ecstasy yeah you
didn't jack off the EXCI I try to get to
anime at Heinen would you do know so um
just I was like rehearsing for I'm
singing at a wedding this upcoming
Saturday yeah so rehearsing the song for
you do it you're in a band with a band
just another person you got a side gig
bro no oh I thought you were like a
woman's role line as a [ __ ] wedding
so yeah you are in Korean weddings
what's your really what's your band's
name there's no band it's just chin it's
Shannon uh Yvonne chin Yvonne Yvonne
when this business come to fruition is
it Ivan as he's a Russian guy that
you're
she's video nice girl oh yeah friend
what kind of music DC it's gonna be pop
you know that song with Megan John
Legend I'm gonna love you like I'm gonna
lose you performing if you off into the
way that's so true like it's so hard to
say you're seeing that where somebody
starts to like somebody thing you're mr.
America and yeah it's super
uncomfortable
my wife Jim I've never I always try to
pay me I never let them pay me if it's
like friends or friends a family or
whatever
usually if I go sing at a wedding then
some people in the wedding will ask
their friends who I am
and then ask me to sing you know I don't
need any money yourself asylum why is it
there said truck uber you got a side
hustle I guess I enjoy seeing so now you
were little am ia this weekend what else
did you do what size party train you
what party
it's a friend's party you know what I
think I got to be quiet with names too
cuz people know like when we say stuff
when I mentioned people they find out
someone find out so yeah now you went to
a party no no about other stuff yeah you
know what luck on duh tinder saw a
tinder for whatever reason is just not
working but I've never had so much so
many options ever at one time right now
outside of tinder how so let's see the
girl himself I met a girl you that
weekend at the party I have to be very
careful with names but met a girl there
you can call her cool okay white girl no
Asian so there's that and then other
girls that I'm
messaging on Instagram that you know
about already to potential potential
well Soto
sorry I told you I would go on a date
with at least one of them this week and
then I'll get you oh there's going on
legit date I'm just gonna yeah do you
want to happen you want to take care of
it I think if you want to do I don't
know show up let's show up about I guess
you guys have a show this week let's get
the door for you
just keep getting the runaround cuz I
don't really know what they're doing on
the weekend but some shit's going on
dude you know we're gonna find a
solution NJ card like I'm just pregnant
with Jim's prize for you guys yeah yes
something's going on I mean just they've
been using this office just a bub slap
uh see my gonna date this weekend yeah
well this week this week this week
sometime this weekend I'll report have
you asked her yet no I already know what
do you mean you know I'm real confident
right now I'm pretty damn confident
about it yeah sometimes you feel it you
ever cell phone talking to Instagram
cell phone on that one you pick up on
that when somebody's attract to you like
you you know you look at me a little too
long sometimes that's normal you can
feel when a guy wants to do more than
just wrestle you you know what I mean
hold your head down in this dick and I
don't well where'd you meet this girl
out you had a friend's party but I got
to be careful
cuz they'll know what I'm saying is she
you don't have to buy it now he's being
very he's being very cryptic you think
she listened to the show
we know it's funny I didn't think other
people would have listened to it but
when I talk like I mentioned other
people before it got to some of those
people and it hurt their feelings not
hurt it was just kind of like
overwhelming like it was their surprise
that so many people would have heard it
hmm because it seems like their lives
are out there they were cool about it
though but they were sad you said we're
so had ever about anybody know anything
but I think we did mention stuff that
maybe like that one quiet what would you
say what
well I heard ain't funny how one word
yeah you know the slope oh my god this
guy in Philadelphia this guy who was
like he great guy really he's bouncing
he was like kind of security for uh but
he was kind of a half a gangster really
quite like him and he shows up with a
girl his girls drunk and he's like he's
just one of those guys he's just one of
those Philly hard guys and he's like you
guys yeah I'm at I turned her and sat
out I got okay oh don't
sorry Turner and I go yeah it was loud
and he goes a man first pack a knife
does she got [ __ ] skull [ __ ] and I
figured her [ __ ] oh my oh
other words that tamed her she's gonna
[ __ ] figure [ __ ] sorry I got her I
don't care white guys to that this is
like his girl he marked a road that's
like a book but that's his way of
bragging in other words I'm saying my
owner again obey it to her that other
guys haven't you know I doubt that
playboy but in that we're when people
talk like that yeah guys I marked her up
[ __ ]
Wow okay cool me all right bro I don't
well let me get this metal up for hold
on this baseball player is really big
and you're standing there just trying
guy and he goes he had a drink and he
goes here's to come and can't come in or
come on I was like Oh cheers I guess
well chin where you gonna take any idea
where you do this date you want help
from us on this yes I mean and James
such good advice already well MJ might
be able to help you know honestly that
if you guys had a show that would've
been dope man yeah well we don't know I
know
so you can see store and drama so I'm
sure that they come sorry kill every
night
Julian we can get you take it yeah I'm
gonna I see a picture ever but we get
you tickets all right
it's not a bad night right what you
should do Kitana
it would have been an awesome if you
guys that were actually there on stage
though oh man maybe another time maybe
maybe time to cut the umbilical cord
solo I need you guys yeah and then and
then what you do is you take her to you
get face timeless we'll do our bit for
us who she is in five minutes
sushi do five minutes at katana yeah
funny yeah we'll just come just FaceTime
and we'll sit down at a table stand up
our hands will be roaming and and we
just stand up you know I mean I'll post
something on Instagram but but here's
another thing I'm worried about the girl
or something like if we're hanging out
I'm worried about everyone listening is
gonna like write comments and stuff and
it's gonna get back to her too well
that's what I'm worried well then turn
your comments off for just that one post
yeah when you post about her but I don't
think you're gonna get that I think
people are gonna be a pain we're happy
that you're not no not there they're the
best that's the problem they're gonna be
like saying oh thank gosh enjoy it but
don't tag her huh just don't tag her on
it dude everyone will find out really
I'm so surprised a date with Nicki Minaj
everybody no no she's not famous or
anything but I'm surprised how many
people that I never thought would ever
find out about this show already know
about it because they have friends of
friends that listen to the show
we got some letters from God take a
chance freaking crazy it kind of blew my
mind a little bit yeah so so you're not
to be a little careful I'll figure
something out I like show it what how
being weird
iq spooked us like maybe take a selfie
alright I can just send you guys don't
send it to us you'll have to blast on
switch B like for a secret video I don't
know table like her what'd you say I
don't know if I would really like her
but alright bro you're already shooters
you said you don't like her you said
this long that's most alright well now
you just shot yourself in the foot
she's probably like okay just going to
edit the part we went out early like I'm
just gonna I don't know if I like her
board is [ __ ] on a Tuesday night I
love those girls are you ever gone the
apes of girls and they just want to
prove to you that they're not impressed
with you or they just don't like you
they're just their defenses are up how
weird is that wonder or they or they
want to insult you he's probably drunk
I'm sure everyone's like oh my god
you're the best well I think you're
[ __ ] stupid oh great on it's a track
through the floor cut you to act like
though my god or you you know I can't
what's up nothing [ __ ] god damn it
what's wrong with you
it's like the boys you're the opposite
yeah it's him
yeah don't do that if you're listening I
[ __ ] hate you scumbag
it's my crush just playing well no my
friends don't play like that take a fat
dick to your face clap go ahead Jim what
does it also car mats yeah my friend
just sent me this so let's see what I
couldn't edit out where you said oh who
cares Lourdes [ __ ] oh no don't worry
about it so yeah no way
so Tom Petty no found unconscious in a
full cardiac arrest
damn get the [ __ ] out of here duh
drug-related he's dead then Santa Monica
Hospital he died then didn't say die did
it no he's put on life support
how old conditions unknown critical for
okay so critical from the morning it was
found old 66 is 66 [ __ ] bummer
keep going damn so it's still developing
I never get if you get there he just
wrapped a huge tour damn damn damn damn
he wraps a huge tour and then oh well is
he I'm not the bigot like I know Tom
Petty is for God's sake so I'm not the
biggest fan but he's really in is he
still in the drug and stuff for - I
don't know if he ever was what sounded
like no Tom Petty was oh wow
straight up is he and he's a straight
shooter straight lazy yeah I know he's a
legend I know he is but no drug-related
and put has been putting out music you
know just never did a tour last Monday
yeah Hollywood ball
wow what else get chin god damn it
Oh Jay Simpson is released
I saw people already hating on him like
you probably gas station and yeah that's
a video that I have heard I would see
the are so what is it it's just a
paparazzi just came out because he just
got released and the paparazzi somehow
find them please for me this in Vegas I
like beating a dead horse I don't even
know
juice juice how's it feel to be out
juice I wish she was drinking juice Oh
y'all be y'all stalking me Jesus where
you guys had one no none of your
business
- I'm in the car for the last five hours
how do I know
and amen look I've been to know where
Khalid I've been to know where USA for
the last nine years doing nothing
nothing has changed in my life what are
you guys happy what he weeks back I've
been that's nothing change please I got
a break here thank you
it doesn't look bad what has changed
you know what he's only been into cars
here's a legit poison him what do you
mean no car he snuck out of the prison
at late at night so that Robinson listen
within a week of OJ getting released
those people can't doubt that's he's
like what do you want me to do I've been
doing life in the [ __ ] car man prison
card nothing oh wait I don't have
anything for you know where you know
they were they were trying to the
district attorney and Florida's trying
to keep him out of Florida cuz you know
what they go to Florida be close to his
kids yeah they were trying to get him
ban from going to Florrick he's not
probation and they're trying to give not
too good Florida might let him see his
kids too I don't care I mean I know but
I mean how he's out now right he did his
time he got acquitted
you know I will how much did the laws
the law I mean you know he beat the law
whether or not yeah I don't know I don't
get any satisfaction of him getting more
punishment I mean I can imagine things I
haven't been so good for him in the past
30 years it's been 20 years of 30 years
it was nine years that he was in prison
right yeah the chase was in June of 94
Wow yeah the Broncos are coming back to
isn't like the car the Bronco
yeah the bronc comes out to UM get one
can't wait oh my god are you oh yeah
that was the car he was piston have you
seen it the numbers games I like that
car long is it cool oh it's so nice um
maybe I'll get that car bad boy I love
that style I love it
nice hair would be oh jeez yeah oh yeah
that's not the new one
no no Ford wants nothing doing I like
that red Red's course [ __ ] those are all
prototypes oh we're all exactly the new
ones oh is that right even saying it
first supposed to look like that so
what's going on to an eighth home so no
it's gonna
version of that but those are like that
why do they do prototypes what does that
mean
I'll show you have an idea what's gonna
look like mm-hmm yeah because I always
and I have this car and I was like I
want that car and the guy goes hey
jackass that's a prototype yeah what's
that say officially I'll happen yeah
that's pretty old I think I'm looking
but it's gonna look somewhat like that
style at ya akhi aha hopefully I'll be
out of Jason I can be on that can I be
at USC games I don't know would we if he
was in your neighborhood B would you be
worried about a little no OJ Simpson not
even a little bit you worried about the
white guy all of them I'm worried about
the 64 year old white guy I'm worried
about everything I'm not worried about
OJ Simpson Wow
there's nobody everything including old
you know what do you mean like he's
gonna kill you no I just murder people a
good guy [ __ ] bro we you're one of the
toughest guys I know the toughest guys
in the world how you how are you a Bob I
don't want him around my neighborhood
shadow ops you completely be quiet don't
you wouldn't know Jason and I wouldn't
give a [ __ ] if he lived across the
street from me that's cuz you'd [ __ ]
idolize him better I just wait I think
he's you wouldn't attack a street for me
I wouldn't care I wouldn't want all the
paparazzi there and stuff but I wouldn't
care about
I don't think OJ's gonna kill me no he's
like kill you
ya know that being said on what one was
my neighbor
I just wouldn't I wouldn't care honestly
I really would I mean you know would it
affect that property value of my house
you think those key things you think
about but you know otherwise I think
there are other things to worry about as
case in point of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
from Las Vegas I mean what do you mean
you can't worry about that yeah do
anything you know you try to be safe
with one thing and something else hits
you in the face I don't know a lot of
people are asking if you guys would ever
have him on the show I'm sure you've
seen that before I have people asking
that I wish I would have him on the show
and I wouldn't ask him about the things
that people are obviously asking him I'd
ask him about other things
I think you know what what other things
be just what is what what he plans to do
with the rest of his life what he's
learned what his point of view is on the
justice system
I'd be interested to hear those kinds of
thoughts I don't think you'd come on and
talked about the other things you know
I'm saying like he's like come on and
talk about the murder what his
experience in jail was like I talked
about in fear yeah the state of football
you know like now would he go back and
do it that's it that's a really having
some real issues from you know brain
trauma
you think he had he is I haven't seen
that I haven't seen any evidence that
what do you mean like kill two people
that you can't blame that on CTE
necessarily people killed a study just
came out and his prosecutors came out
said if the trial is going today the
fact Department I'm sure I'm sure what
he said he would have pled to insanity
from the brain trauma I don't okay
Simpson says I'm sure but I doubt that
that would have gotten I very much doubt
that doesn't matter what you think what
that would happen
the issue here is a jason says he has
brain trauma and suffers from it okay
but that's fine that OJ Simpson says
that but I'm saying that way before that
when we didn't know anything about that
nobody was talking about CTE when he
killed those people and he was a young
man or a lot younger and by the way even
now I don't see it's not like he's I
don't see any signs of that around
because he's over well she's slurring of
speech you know so well well but there
but you but I don't see any signs of him
that doesn't work what I'm saying is he
you don't know and I don't know and I'm
saying Oh Jay Simpson from the his mouth
said he has it so I'm going to take that
over Brian conscious I'm sure he is
saying he hasn't done the interview in
nine years or he is saying that and and
by the way especially when that would
have been a defense he said it long
before this he said it long before it
when during he's been till he's talked
about brain trauma before he's even on
trial I know for him I never heard that
he's talked about brain I mean he's
talked about before yeah
like Tony Dorsett when Tony Dorsett
talks about not being able to remember
things getting angry headaches all the
time
that's that's a guy who's clearly
suffering from CTE and talks about it
whether or not I've never seen anything
you know remotely you know that
represents that with OJ never I haven't
heard that correlated with him at all so
whether or not he has it doesn't you
know I think from playing thirty years
of football like I said I wouldn't be
surprised but again that's not something
I've seen from OJ like I don't I I
haven't even heard that in correlation
to him but what he'll be like this what
would you need to see where you where
Bryan Callen would decide well I would
imagine that when you are complaining
about memory loss slurring of speech the
various signs and symptoms of CTE
massive depression and things that we
know a lot of football players have
talked to but you don't think Oh Jason I
don't know massive depression oh the
answer is I don't know haven't seen it
well I will say fast that you don't
think he has it um I don't know like I
said I don't know I just haven't that's
not something that I attribute to him
when I see him speaking like especially
when he's like during the trial in 93
yeah well no even even even when he was
like he's so like when he was talking
about when he's pleading with the judge
and stuff right when he was pleading
with the judge and say I didn't mean to
hurt anybody when he had you know and
they with jobs gonna in Vegas gonna put
him away for nine years
like I saw nothing but again I'm not an
expert on CT all I'm saying is that I
don't see it you know I don't see it I
don't see anything I don't see any signs
of it that's what I'm saying but I don't
know does he could he have it after
playing football for that long a hundred
percent you know I'm and not what I'm
trying to get and what's so frustrating
to me is I think when you go you're not
brain trauma because I forget things we
say what do you say you you looked at me
like you were saying especially cuz he's
having so many problems with brain
trauma or CTE and I went he is and you
turn no you said I don't think he has no
no no no I didn't because you I say I
don't you said from the interviews I've
seen he don't seem to have it he does
not seem that I've never what I'm saying
let's just let's stop there well I'm
saying there is if you think you who
I do you know how much about brain
trauma I just said I'm saying if you
think you can watch an interview and
based off if someone has brain trauma
based off a simple I 30-second you clip
of him pleading his in you no no I
didn't say that would you did you said
look to me like it was obvious that he's
having always problems CT I've never
heard that in the nervous it'll be
you're saying based off the video where
he goes where he's pleading his case to
get out of jail right you say based off
that video he doesn't have brain trauma
right according to you right and what am
I didn't say he doesn't he doesn't look
eyes ever
you said exact and based off that energy
and and I don't think either one of us
know whether or not he's suffering from
CT now he may have correct now what I'm
saying what I'm saying is if you think
you can watch a 30 minute clip and base
that off that healing their brain
traumas crazy that's all I'm saying I
dream that's it yeah I agree
so when you go okay when you go I when I
watch this video and he's on a brain
trauma no no I said I don't know and
I've never attributed CT with OJ Simpson
he's day I just never be all I'm saying
this started with you saying based off
the interview I saw him give I don't
think his brain true it started with you
going especially with all the problems
he has with CTE and I went he hasn't
never heard that I haven't heard him say
that and and you went yeah I think no
hundred percent ECT yeah I would bet my
life on it
I'm sure if you play football for thirty
years again I just haven't heard of OJ
Simpson and maybe he talked about it and
they said they would have brought it up
in this defense or in his trial which
makes sense now that we know all this
but it's the first time I'm hearing
about it you know with him so I don't
know man yeah no one knows but there are
plenty of guys who were running backs
who have you know Tony Dorsett and those
guys I'm sure they're funny people see
to you that would never ever harm
someone and there's people that would
arms yeah a lot of times it's just you
know it's depression or but you know all
kinds of the symbol and symptoms but you
know you don't know and shows up later
on for some guys shows up you know or
you don't even know you know or you
attribute your depression to something
else that's CTE or your lack of energy
or whatever it might be I mean I don't
know I didn't see that movie concussion
I don't know a whole lot about it but
apparently it makes your brain spun
right it's so heavy to get into and it
affects people differently - shall we
jump to the next mm-hmm there's a story
of a woman in Ohio that faked her own
kidnapping on the Facebook live there
and then panties she's in jail now yeah
she put underwear in her mouth why did
she do it there's no reasoning other
than people think she just wants
attention
yeah - she asked for money anything No
so she her family and friends saw the
post and they called police immediately
and they freaking closed down the
highway had helicopters to come out have
full force come out did she have to
cover that bill that's that's a good
question wait wait so um do you know
what they say named Lance is how much a
few thousand if no if you don't have
insurance yes like a few thousand right
oh not so much money I'm gonna guess
five thousand Oh way now that helicopter
you all Betsy said I'm ambulance I think
ten grand that might be all right though
well so they they charge you right I
might be able to look it up Jim how much
uh um four hundred twelve hundred that's
pretty cheap uh yeah but you got if you
got a helicopter and they shut down the
highway you got all those cops
you're [ __ ] me thousand that crazy
wait can you um so is there a video of
it she put the video up on Facebook yeah
you can see some here and she just wants
attention I mean there's no other reason
why she would have done it don't make a
weird choices and now she's in prison
she's in jail no I mean this is it let's
see if it's taken down I mean it looks
like she took a selfie and so she put it
on Facebook and her friends were like
holy [ __ ] it's still up there right on
well that's a picture yeah well I saw
the video earlier it's just her kind of
like that's it little tiny thing and it
says we have your girl
was she trying to get money from her
family it says nothing about that I
faith in her yes but the comments are
brutal this guy goes under is all she
found I guess tape would have ripped
that much this put this lady but my
chalk fake a better kidnapping than this
[ __ ] that let me run say Haney's were
not gagging you you could have just spit
them out I'm going to fake it after it
started shaking my head you didn't think
this through oh she's in jail for how
long though and you're in jail for what
wasting state resources yeah I think you
mentioned that how long charges fifth
degree felony felony to fake a imagine
should be yeah I think so too
and she will be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law so she's making says
we can actually see this is the
attorneys we can actually see her
waiting for the video to come on so she
can get her serious face on no mind her
story to be totally fabricated Sheriff
Richard Jones
she's kids to ask for it was there every
woman who said she Gardens where is it
she's got what she just needs help so
maybe I suggest some mental issues was
it was there ever any further
development of this story without that
that British woman is kidnapped by the
Albanian mafia or the Russian people
like people are sending me stuff that
they think it's fake or they're thinking
it's fake but every time I look it up
online it doesn't show fake people are
just put on the dark web so there might
be some inside fake things that you know
some people might be reading but people
just most passed it yeah guys who kidnap
women and they found their mothers I
don't know it still doesn't make sense
they're not know it's not like they're
the most yeah like I mean what do you do
with that oh look look on the left
caught lying about her ordeal Oh rogues
and tears when times
caught her lying as they quizzed her
that she was drugged and bummer but
black death gang she is
oh she's painfully hot yes she really is
but and you know she may be alive what
happened like I wanted to know that I
can help her yeah yeah see so the guys
that are accused of kidnapping her are
being extradited Michael could be
assured to join the civil interface
allegations are getting at the model
that was quizzed by police
you're not gonna they can they can find
out a lot second real the model was
asked about the track suit and shoes she
was wearing she was handing them the
house were they all in it together
that's what it sounds like they would
have to be if ya just get the money
she's very hot though she's ridiculous
like that guy looks like isn't it hot
hot so part of the story was alive then
she went with that guy to buy shoes the
kidnapper okay another interview a
police I've asked her if she thought it
was strange she went to buy shoes with
the alleged captor yeah so some of her
story is in that net but oh no she's
full of [ __ ] man
oh yeah yeah well see she's just trying
to attention she's obviously
ridiculously hot got hired publicist
girl go back guys - there's a real risk
that this entire case is a sham that's
her no the biggest bad get ever well so
I think she's full of [ __ ]
either way you keep doing the thing go
doing a bang come on hand tell your
story mm-hmm come on hand please you're
innocent we'll figure out a lot
terrifying moment a shark narrowly
misses those are never watching let's
see oh hello
was supposed to be at a concert and I
guess the security team at that venue
said that they have to go through
security screaming screening and he just
refused so he just didn't do the concert
cuz yeah because they carry guns and
[ __ ] guns drugs yeah so he wouldn't go
through it and so he just can't he just
said screw it I'm not gonna be party
like almost dead - just like two weeks
ago no wasn't he in the hospital yeah he
always has seizures talked about I
talked about drinking scissor scissor
right and now so many people reached out
but we have to be in Texas to do it
what happened remember I said I want to
try little Wayne's oh yeah so many
people reached out I'm down to try it I
feel like it's troubled us I'll try it
you'll try it you I'll try it I'm like
you haven't done a lot of drugs Austrian
ban on full face fail in public places
comes into force can I be honest with
you
yeah I'm not mad at that law because I
don't know who the [ __ ] is behind that
veil it just scares me
could be a white guy who's 64 with a gun
it's so tough though because if that's
their religion you know that's their
customs how can you ban him from doing
that uh well I kind of feel like if you
were well so when I lived in Saudi
Arabia you could not wear shorts I was a
little boy and I was not allowed to wear
shorts and it's a hundred degrees out
goodnight and if you wore shorts the
religious police and if you and if a
woman showed her ankles or the religious
place would come out and hit you with a
stick all right and so you know and oh
and by the way you couldn't have you
couldn't really worship you couldn't
have a church and started Rabia at the
time so we had to respect the customs
and the cultures of that country they're
very religious Wahhabi form of Islam
I feel like have you come to Austria
with a tradition yeah of liberal
policies and by the way you're also
benefiting from those liberal policies
from that liberal sort of democracy I
feel like there should be at least some
conversation on whether or not you
should respect the customs of that
particular so when you are in a class in
France and you happen to be say Muslim
and you object to a cross on the wall
when it when it is a Christian nation
with the history of that country like
damn and stuff like that would you know
it was founded under those sort of
Christian principles it's just part of
the fabric of the culture and I feel
like when you object to that and it
offends your personal sensibilities
you're still you're still a guest in
that country and you're benefiting from
the it's a tough one man I don't know
it's it's a tough one III have sympathy
for some of it I don't know it's a it's
a weird line to go to it because I don't
know obvious Muslims veils such as the
burqa net but also places restrictions
on these of medical face masks and clown
makeup well one's a religious reason the
other a clown makeup
wow that's like they're trying to cover
their ass in terms of tracking around a
loophole Allah says and that's my
religion an estimated hundred fifty
women wear the full burqa in Austria but
tourism officials have expressed fears
that measures will also dieter visitors
from the Gulf yeah I think um I I feel
like the burqa is God I don't know how
many women would actually like wearing
that I just feel like if they come to a
European country they should be allowed
to make their own choice and maybe I can
see women's activist going these women
are being told that that's how they have
to dress even though there is their
customs we really want to wear that you
did any human being want to look through
through that through a mesh thing do you
really want to be covered like that I
don't think you do and I think that
that's and I lived in that part of the
world and [ __ ] yeah I feel they grow up
like that you got to walk around like
that you know starting at the age of
what 13 14 I don't know man they sure in
the shade yeah I just don't get it it's
it's it's I come on yeah I mean look at
that look at that little sketch in
alright check this out
this old dude drives I think ours to go
to this lake to visit his friend snake
and check out how they are wait his
friends snake well his friend the snake
female
I got a perch here check it out I mean
recognizes him oh hey girl [ __ ] there
not a snake is that it's a diamond
Valley lard water snake comes right to
his leg piped up cuz I don't want one
cross through tied my britches that
would be kind of bad this is why people
get bit in the neck and [ __ ] no she's
not oh she's a pretty thing came right
up to me I wonder she let me help her
[ __ ] her filming Blair Witch for I mean
hold the camera study Braille 79 I hope
I got that well you did pretty good
yeah Jesus Christ I would never do that
I would cuz they're not gonna bite you
we used to catch snakes they ever walk
up to you I mean I walk up snow in
Maryland wait my buddy and I am Bowie we
used to go we caught big snakes like
that big water snakes like that and
they're they don't bite it well you want
to make sure it's not a water moccasin
that would suck they'll bite the [ __ ]
out of you and you you're in big trouble
Jesus Christ that's what they look like
they there was these giant snakes I was
14 I was like [ __ ] it no snakes creeped
me out
really I don't I had pet snakes that's
why I don't they don't freak me out well
sketch in this it's a cool little
article on bleacher report eight
fighters are the best post MMA careers
as of now who's that giant girl that's a
Stephanie McMahon so Vince McMahon's
daughter and then that's her husband
Triple H Chabot who runs WWE right
Rhonda what's the same so boom Keith
Jardine he's got a coffee thing right
he's got kale coffee hey man coffee hit
eight do it together huh
and then but he's also horns go up to
Keith Keith is also yeah he does stunt
work in Hollywood yep hey man take yeah
and there's Tate powerful mustache and
beard
yep he's in every pretty much every big
action movie but he's my little boy
every move here at work killing it yeah
he's doing big things as always well I
guess he's still yeah he's in a bunch of
business stuff they stood as movies he'd
probably still fight feet or would that
be weird way too late
Ronda Rousey what is Rhonda doing I
think she's getting to the list she's
been so quiet and so out of the
limelight
I guess they should have Ramallah if she
does dirty double year day movies so she
wasn't she was in a little promo on The
WB so she'll probably do something
that's smart such a big fan base such
big money there Brock Lesnar number 4
busy but the thing is Brock was doing
that before he fought in the UFC don't
make sense that Brock on that list you
know I'm saying it's like him seeing
Punk on there I think he's just making a
lot of money as a as an entertainer hmm
right cross he hasn't done my movies
Brock cuz you know John Cena doesn't
want him doesn't want to refuse to do
any other stuff really why oh uh Gina
Carano beautiful Gina Carano is what is
she up to
she's she's in a bunch of she's in a
bunch of it she was in a Deadpool I
don't know if she's gonna be in the
sequel no oh yeah she's in the sequel I
don't know
was she in Deadpool yeah yeah all right
it's very silent but yeah tough oh yeah
and she was dating Superman what oh oh
really
ray caviola or whatever who's the new
Superman Henry Henry Cavill yes the
dimepiece that guy's a stud mm-hmm Oh
what number two who's number one for God
is Susie nobody ray nobody saw this one
coming don't read this keep going god I
don't read this book don't read it all
right fine Brian Stann Brian Stann
number one
that's Brian Stann Wow what's I got you
above Brian Stann though damn by Brian
Stann it's pretty dope spot man well
you're at though let's go back and stay
number one that's getting move what's
that I said Brian Stann number one
interesting over take me out of it but
even over Rockland those guys yeah yeah
I wouldn't put Brian number one that's
that's that's weird to me he proved more
than capable of sharp analysis on time I
don't yeah all right so there we go but
uh I would put just because of notoriety
brock lesnar super famous and with you
he came in famous though yeah you know
I'm saying like Brock came in famous me
the biggest WWE wrestler right now see
by the way by the way though here's the
other thing I would also like like like
so Brock is technically still fighting
and still using his body he's still in
that world you're not so you have to
kind of I don't know if like it you know
I'm saying like Brock's still doing it
we're talking about people who are not
fighting anymore you just fought Mark
Hunt and right and so I feel still in
that fight even w-w-w he was about to
fight he was gonna take that john jones
fight it's true so for me like i don't
think he belongs there so he's out go
back go back let me see something
go back so we got Brian Stann you know
you're ahead of Brian I'm sorry all due
respect to Brian's you can't you can't
put you second and Brian this doesn't
make any sense
keep going your header on don't listen
to anyone is silly but Gina Carano I
mean you know she's way out her yeah but
as far as like somebody who's like doing
a lot of stuff and I feel like I don't
know the world if anything I know and
this is obviously my negative mindset if
anything this list is a bummer there's
not more guys on there yeah if you look
at the list it's kind of like yeah it's
a bummer yeah because if you if you
looked at an NFL list or NBA list like
oh what are guys up to now yeah like I
have guys have played football with who
we're on the 30 under 30 they're in
Forbes you know they're doing some cool
[ __ ] yeah you look at mm a list and you
know
exactly a long list of that's nothing to
really celebrate that's why it's a DMA
is a cruel mistress hate to be a Debbie
Downer shout out to bleacher report for
even recognizing me but it's bit of a
debbie downer because that's the end the
makers that we're celebrating postal
careers
yep it's not yeah it's a cruel mistress
it's a great way to put it
now fans if you look at if you look at
boxers just think about boxers all of
its business-related
like obviously you know Mayweather
promotions Golden Boy Mike Tyson had his
Broadway show brother and that hasn't
been a great ride he stayed he stayed
relevant Tyson I mean he's doing
commercials Mike Tyson yeah cuz he did
you did The Hangover which was good yeah
yeah yeah but yeah yes with George
Foreman performing do you know they
offer that's all Conan he's like nah
Foreman did the Foreman grill so that's
a big one
how many kids is George Foreman have ten
more than that ten not they all named
George George why would you do that just
hoping one of them that's weird
Freeda Foreman George Foreman georgette
Foreman
okay tormund jr. and George Foreman come
on six twelve dozen Evander Holyfield up
more nine twelve so how do you have 12
kids and how the [ __ ] do you keep them
all like I mean that's a lot of money
for Foreman grill cover those kids oh
yes Evander's doing work all starts with
E [ __ ] eleven children
it's a lot of kids yeah I'd say so
just a lot of money what else we got
chin look at this have you seen that
girl whose eyes bled of ink why would
her eye she tattooed her she had her
boyfriend tattoo her eyes you know
sometimes people tattoo their eyeballs
you talking about the prison-style
really go red or blue or black wait on
this girl she's actually please before
you get in this story Google I tattoo in
prison they take a needle and color
their eyes red the white or black I
click on yeah sure but there's better
ones
there's red right there but go up to the
all-black one that's the creepiest [ __ ]
these guys this guy looks crazy they go
red a lot of time so this chick decided
to let her boyfriend tattoo her eyes
well yeah I guess he was trying to get
her to tattoo her eyes she wanted her he
wanted to get his tattoo on her eyes for
so long and then she finally gave in and
he said that he was actually able to do
it well
he was not good at all she might lose
her oh my god
hold up she let her boyfriend tattoo
just a color hit like a logo on her eye
well he always wanted to tattoo that
that color in her eye yeah hold up no
actually she thought it was fine
the 24 year old model model said she
didn't question it because her
ex-boyfriend who injected the purple dye
into the white part of her left eye told
her it was normal he also allegedly said
that it's not unusual for the eye to
swirl up to a huge size there's only
when the man Tony broke up with
Gallinger and she asked other experts
everything was okay and swelling and
vision loss was it normal at all
and now four weeks after getting the
body modification procedure done
Gallinger doesn't know if she'll ever
regain full sight in that eye again
dad don't you [ __ ] die so she
actually went to the hospital to get it
checked but it's it's it's so brand-new
and don't really knew about it they gave
her pain medicine and like anti swelling
medication drops for us can you do for
it and then after like a couple weeks
she finally want to get checked out for
a second opinion and then they put the
needle hold up dilute the ink with
saline he just put pure ink into my and
he was a very large needle went too deep
these two injections one on top man what
are you doing why would you go down more
why would you do this there is I don't
get it there are no nerve endings in
your I guess you don't feel it but I
just don't like what you don't feel it
no apparently you don't feel that it not
funny
shut the [ __ ] you ever got some in your
eye I know but apparently in your the
white of your eye I guess you know you
don't have nervous yeah so I heard
that's why when they do lasix you know
you can get lasix I have LASIK stevia
LASIK hurts did they put anesthesia
though in your eyes yeah so it's a light
that'll hurt but I guess you can stick
certain things I don't know look that
out there no nerve endings and so they
do a little laser though yeah well
that's how her eyes were I pretty all
her eyes were super pretty and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] what you would look even
better put purple in there he really was
AMA done dumbass
he was pushing for it he our fetish and
then he broke up with her huh he's like
your eyes look terrible I'm out sorry
you guys dude here's an eye patch guys
are dicks yeah
what's the eyepatch for it cuz I'm
leaving goddamnit
um so I mean no so there's a chance she
might be able to save her eye but it's
not a hundred percent that's tricky
that's that's a bummer super pretty
no a doctor a surgeon sir I don't think
they know how to deal with it yeah she
went to the doctor they didn't know you
ever say that I'm like can you imagine
doctors like you did what matters I had
a pain in my side and it was just like a
pain that wouldn't go away and I was
like something's wrong man so my doctor
goes I don't know maybe you tore the
interlining I don't
man this is an inner feeling feels like
an organ so he does all my blood work he
goes your liver function ever he's
pretty outstanding and he goes go down
to the surgeon he sent me down he called
a guy who goes do you have a minute
the surgeon who's like I go down and
this guy's like he's like kind of like
this [ __ ] surgeon that deals with
real cases right like and he looks at
man he goes what's going on I got I got
a thing here he goes I heard you think
it's hernia I go yeah might he goes yeah
you'd be the first person I had a double
hernia he goes you you'd be the first
person in the history of the world have
a hernia there but that's okay yeah you
guys he goes um he goes so so can I just
like can I just put you I know what
you're here for
yeah yeah you want to know if you have
cancer that's really what you're here
for
well I mean you know I want to know what
the body goes you don't you guys I think
you toured the inner lining of it get
out of here Christ I'm biased I know you
I feel bad for her you don't feel bad I
mean I was like that's such a precious
thing your eyesight why would you [ __ ]
with that right like correct cuz she was
in love yeah she's known for at least a
month I've done some dumb things for
guys but I would never like tattoo my
eyeball yeah that's so that's why gonna
research it was it in his home was it in
a tattoo shop no it was yeah they were
just together and he he showed like Sam
he showed a portfolio to her of stuff
that he's done so I've I've never loving
anyone enough in this life to tattoo my
especially if you don't want it that's
not what you want to do you're just
doing it because they want you to do it
would you sell your eyeball for 200 yeah
this wasn't have a glass I had my car
accident they did yeah when I first woke
up like literally all bandaged up my
ankles like broken they said I was I'm a
glass eye cuz like all right here all
the bones of my orbital shattered they
had to like pick out bones of my eyeball
the first thing when I woke up what they
said I was no glass I know did you say
did you see when you woke up words are
too much swelling alright here it was
flapped and then alright here was
crushed so I mean I I remember like look
in and out yeah like in and out because
I did you go out after your Access ID
apparently because I went off a cliff so
apparently like I was screaming I didn't
know my name I was like screaming for my
axes number like hey call someone call
someone and then I remember just like
waking in and out because I had a really
bad brain injury like I'm still
recovering like from that really yeah
how long ago was that MJ um four years
Brian rough brain day but like I had to
find a place to live when I got out of
the hospital like my dog like everything
so I didn't even think about my head
were you in the hospital
mmm I was only in it for like a few days
like almost like a week maybe but that
was because of like family stuff I don't
wanna get out of it I should have been
in there how long did you realize that
you weren't gonna lose your I how happy
hmm my I didn't get sowed like it was
still flat for I think at least like 24
for 36 hours it's all messy like I
really I feel like your dumb ass too cuz
when I first met MJ first thing you say
always sounds like her here like yeah
her hair's like that you know I have
this guy here and I looked similar and
it fresh happened my I got opened up
yeah and I went oh dude do you train
like did an elbow on a gin elbow I had
the same thing she's all know this you
into the story cliff yeah I was a car
guy and she pulled a hair back and I
told you I'd [ __ ] hone that I think
it's cool yeah dope it's hard yeah like
I just went to a doctor two weeks ago
because they're putting injections in my
eye to see if like it would stretch it
apart cuz there's no full crease and
that's why this is it scar tissue and
there's so much scar tissue like did you
say [ __ ] I've been through like so many
surgeries and more plastic surgeons
plastic surgeons but like I didn't have
anyone like to tell me how to how do you
handle like after car accident so I
didn't get the proper reimbursement I
started working too soon I've broken
back like didn't do anything for my
brain they didn't like totally did not
take care of myself I was just I was 19
I didn't know what I mean it's not yeah
it's so embarrassing right listen I know
it might be embarrassing for you but let
me I told John you're a beautiful girl
yeah like I told the first time I met
her I told her that I said I would
[ __ ] own that I said anything I think
it makes you a guy it wouldn't bother me
at all I don't think it would allow then
guys go yes really
I prefer it yeah I don't know it's still
in security that's why I don't like go
out much I keep to myself are you
kidding me okay it's like I said stolen
security within myself like I have to
get through my god so I still get asked
I don't feel pretty if I listen to me
I'm watching to be like one of those
girls that you know that I don't that I
understand but I understand and I can I
can sympathize with that I'm sure it's
very hard for as a woman but just take
it from court me him chin and all the
guys that have been guests here you got
no problem in the looks department
I promise you I'd love to like help
girls I've gone through like many like
facial deformities maybe go into some
sort of charity work through that cuz
there's been girls have come up to me
they've been like grabbing to your eye
then all of sudden want toes at the
library this girl peeled back and she
had a scar like all the way back to here
and she was like ten years down the line
for women for women it's stuff like for
guys it's like it's like a badge of
honor like it's dope like two guys see
your scars my god that's cool for girls
the guy was at this party my neighbor's
party and they were on vacation and the
girls she's gonna be a freshman high
school this happened two weeks before
her this has just happened two weeks
before the start of her freshman year in
high school
she's on a she's there surfer in Hawaii
on family vacation there's another
surfer there Dancy her and his surfboard
hit her in the eye in the face and like
I mean just scar like oh and so they
left early they left that day back
they're late it's trying to see a
surgeon do all that and she I'm just
like God you know I was trying to be
like man it doesn't look bad and like if
we don't scar like her down so we're
just gonna scar cuz we have girls it's
just a different animal which is fun
yeah it's gotta be about us and own it
eventually it's a love/hate own it
really on its own it I'm Toni MJ it
makes you unique and I think it's a
badass story and it gives you character
look great you're out yeah you are
you're gorgeous girls so if you were
ugly all over then it's like well yeah I
guess I own it I mean you know like what
the [ __ ] is you dying your problems are
not your problem
no they really really aren't I mean
honestly you know I don't the [ __ ] out
of that right I got self-conscious of my
ears but I say looking guy you know like
like my face like you get you see jaw
you see you get lost in my eyes
you get lost in the symmetry of what's
going on with my chest not in all
seriousness I think a lot of times like
girls think they're the only ones who
have those like issues of confidence I
know yeah I'd love to buy this morphia
but you gotta realize my conscious I'm
still in but you know you look at like
the rock or you know that like these
days guys you're compared to there's
these girls too
that's really so it's like that's not
real that's a such an interesting point
because like if the way we came up and
we evolved as I remember but for most of
our most of human history you came from
a small village you didn't have the
internet you didn't really say it used
to went to the movies and saw the movies
in a movie house but for the most part
you were comparing yourself to the
people in your immediate vicinity to the
hundred and fifty two hundred people
that you grew up around three hundred
and if you were a regular dude you were
really only comparing yourself to the
regular dude regular it's all good so so
girls too right so you didn't have now
teenagers and all of us we have access
to the most the best-looking athletes
the best looking actors the best looking
you know everybody and so models until
you're so it's impossible as you're
coming up especially when you're your
age not even models to a good point be
like night not even models to like you
know like Kim Kardashian she's not a
model but finishing she posts on
Instagram it's completely fabricated and
frost and right so kylie jenner like
doctor that's real that's not real it's
all that money so what happens is all of
us are like comparing ourselves to
Connie it's happening to men too it's
like everybody it's like you know you
think you're completely ugly like and
then because you're always exposed to
but I'll see the most gorgeous girl in
the world on Instagram and some will put
some on there like oh your eyes are too
close together like but before you never
have to deal with any of that ever yeah
it's a scam whenever we're all competing
it's our entire world it's scary for
women especially they have to live up to
up for men to that you know you deal
with it same thing to men men men for
sure to because now there's like
pressure on men to be hey like it used
to be like
you don't even humphrey bogart you see
his body he was a sex symbol back in the
day you see his body yeah you know Paul
was actually in shape on them but I mean
yeah but same thing it's like you never
thought about that now men are very
self-conscious about it actors had taken
steroids when they work out when they do
so you know I mean yeah it's magazines
like Instagram you know those like
Instagram fitness models women and men
like that you gotta realize a lot of
them are dieting just for that photo
shoot like that's not they don't walk
around like that like that guy you see
how Muscle & Fitness that's photoshopped
airbrushed he was on a 12-week [ __ ]
diet was eating a crouton and a nice
cube for the last 12 week he's not
living you don't want the streets like
that when you watch a movie they don't
walk the streets like that Ben Affleck
doesn't look like Batman right now yeah
it's impossible to keep your body on
that like you know it's just kind of
crazy but I get it I mean like Aditi
your point that's exactly right we're
just constantly bombarded with these
images of perfection and it's only gonna
get worse I don't see a gutter it's
weird too though like what is beauty
like there's no natural beauty though
anymore like with girls like injecting
themselves constantly like there is I
thought there is I used to think I'd
good lips but now like someone can buy
them [ __ ] up MJ you're dealing with
the machine you can't compare its
natural beauty there is natural beauty
but the you if you go on the Instagram
you see a fake girl like like that's
Instagram beauty I guess that's not real
and guys can smell it from a mile away
she's doing that more for friends and go
on Instagram but in if you ask any guy
in person or would you rather have blac
chyna or MJ most guys and go MJ because
you're natural yeah like there's nap
don't don't get twist by the system also
guys taking steroids hate to tell you
most girls aren't into that man you look
good for your buddies yeah you're
shredded man that's cool
most girls aren't digging that acne on
your back your mood swings the
injections and also like it's really
easy to compare have to compare as
opposed to like how look at where you've
come from
kind of like compare where you can't
where you what you were doing before
this and stuff like that it's tends to
be it's really hard not to kind of you
know you
during the arena with everybody it's
with everything even sports like in high
school if you were let's he went to Shea
Creek High School in Denver and you were
the [ __ ] man there we go on Instagram
he rushed for 200 yards that game like
damn I'm I'm gonna be the [ __ ] man
well cool this kid in Texas I can go on
Instagram right now you're us for six
hundred yards yeah when before we have
no idea we toured stories well you know
to this a little bit I'm sure you've had
this experience you know and you're
during a different physical class than
that you're good-looking guy and all but
but I'm sure even you like when you're
in Hollywood and you go on an audition
and this has happened to me for 20 years
and I I've told the story but you know
when you're a young guy and I was kind
of cute I was considered a cute guy like
I was like considered a guy who suits or
whatever like that and then you'd go to
that audition room and you would see the
best with all all the guys who can't
Holly but were the best-looking guys and
the best you know everyone was hold on
athletes everyone everyone okay
everyone's a homecoming queen and queen
and king and they're sitting in that
waiting room and you're like oh Jesus oh
I'm not a ho ho I mean at all I'm not
gonna say her name but a woman we would
all I'll take off everywhere we'd all
known here I'm shooting this pilot with
her and they go alright cut for this TV
show and then she goes ooh ooh she's
staring at me she's been great we've had
great chemistry and she was oh and
points my hair I have no issues with my
[ __ ] no no I love my hair yeah she
was oh can we Oh golly I can't believe I
see this earlier you have a spot right
here with your cowlick
it looks like you're going bald there
yeah you know what have you I can't
believe you came on set with that I'm
like Duff [ __ ] are you talking about she
was in the front it's little details
it's either a cowlick or you're going
bald in the front then I'm definitely
going bald I have to reframe my hair
from running my eyebrow she goes yeah
it's one of the two you know what can we
get a spray can Chris get a spray hurt
on her she's a rock now for you hmm
then what are you guys doing no no don't
[ __ ] spray the middle of my forehead
I'm not going bald that's my hairline
you [ __ ] yeah but I was like oh my god
yeah weird though uh you should have
seen her I thought I thought a [ __ ]
eagle was hatched out of my shoe
oh oh I can't believe it earlier
although that's somebody who's that's
somebody who were sure has seen how that
looks on camera you know I had I did a
bad movie and looking back and I never
should have done it buddy well blue
terrible it's [ __ ] it was called
sleeping around mr. terrible movie and
spent six weeks in North Carolina and
I've bill yeah the whole idea was bad
but the the women were tired and they
were real amateurs one of the women who
was doing makeup took a [ __ ] that you
know the dusted I swear to you I swear
to God
she was looking at me I was looking at
her and so today she went she had it's
like just so it's a brush right yeah she
goes like this
gang gang right in my [ __ ] eye she
goes I go I don't even do makeup I was
just asked him and I go yeah hear that
that's it then they had two other girls
we hadn't done I realized where like
they'd never done wigs before and they
put wigs on these girls they look the
problem is I stopped everything let me
explain something to you guys you have
to know something I know isn't not a
terrible movie the promise this could be
on Showtime and the promise he could run
forever it was gonna ruin everything
yeah and so for the next 20 years we see
you with this ridiculous [ __ ] wig and
it really everybody forgets about you
they don't forget about the actor yeah
so it's little things like that long
story short I was talking to uh who was
Ozzie Kelly I'm a little girl in the guy
for you to assigning a zoo not me man on
this world not in this day and age I'm
already dealing with it my daughter's
nine I'm dealing with it already
oh yeah they're already competitive they
date who they look listen to who they
look up to how they dress how they
behave they have cell phones already
know like kids I've been babysitting
like six and seven they have Kitley
there you have access to the phone well
they love that iPad yeah dangerous
though Rock yes just like phones yeah
instant gratification yeah
I heard Whitney come Sam Rogan that the
average person checks their Instagram on
average 35 times a day I thought
addicted we are doing yeah I believe
that
oh yeah why does your honors you check
it but yeah usually you go through you
explore and you see all the cool like
you know videos of people jumping in the
air lions biting people hey I really I
drill I don't really explore on their
ear yeah I do yeah I know he do yeah
CrossFit amazing lifters you know I
follow this really cool weapon anyways
MJ any back damn day if anything I don't
think you're the only one that suffers
from that but you have you're from us
here and we would not [ __ ] you you
need to I'm narrow not got I told that
the first day about it I do lucky and I
should bear muffs and you should wear
earmuffs but we don't J yeah we don't we
don't and I shouldn't wear pants cuz
it's me Brian should buy a wig but he
doesn't but I don't bought it down
merely but Invisalign that lasted three
days I'm wearing it
I've never seen you wear it yeah I don't
wear it when I do the podcast you've
never seen on the first week it's you
just not that guy who's gonna commit
response [ __ ] my teeth up more I think
they do look old [ __ ] it's bringing one
of my teeth down oh do I have to call
them just do the regular old school
braces right I'm not doing regular old
school bleep friendship Rock of comedy
yeah basis for ever
Frankie's very issue no I'm not doing
that is that it for Kermit so no we got
on this you know when I first met Brian
to the first thing you showed me you
didn't really teeth talk to me that much
you know we're in the elevator and then
we're going up the elevator he was just
showing me his Instagram with he wasn't
exploring all the different fight scenes
and yeah I think it workout stuff yeah
let's put the very first day I do
amazing lifters super athletes I do all
that mm-hmm
I'm gonna do a dropping knowledge but we
have to take a break yeah I got a piece
so hard again my driving ology is
essentially about how truth
the value of myth the value even of
religion the value of agreeing for human
beings to agree on a story agree on a
contract because there are different
kinds of truth we've talked about right
mathematical true certain biological
truths we know that there's energy in an
atom because when you split it and
[ __ ] you know crazy science of math
yeah truce weekend yeah they're
irrational treaty numerical values yeah
but then there are other like there are
other truths that I think are
fascinating I want to read one of the
most famous lines from the Declaration
of Independence and I want you to think
about this for a second and and and one
of the truth to keep in mind also is it
well let me let me go through it we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness now I just want you guys to
think about something for a second
that's actually taken directly from the
Christian faith a lot of the framers of
the Constitution the framers that were
if not they were they came from the
Christian tradition they may not have
been completely by their creator so so
the idea that we were created by one
creator yeah means that we're all
related that we're all children of God
yes which makes us brothers and sisters
which then makes us all of established
as of the same moral worth so that again
in the eyes of Allah the well in the
eyes of the law if I kill somebody who's
mentally handicapped even though they're
not equal to you and I like so you know
biologically you could look at somebody
who's too severely handicapped and say
that there's nothing equal about that
relationship we also know that
biologically that statement is not true
biologically we all come down with
different mutable characteristics our we
we are a function of our genetic code
which is vastly different we're all very
different we're a function of the
environment we were born in and all of
these things make us more resistant
disease less resistant to disease more
resistant to you know stresses more
athletic less athletic taller towards
sale but you know to what I'm saying is
that from a biological point of view we
know now especially with the way men
and is coming about that there's nothing
equal about human beings human beings
are very very different and we've we
haven't and so again from a biological
point of view we weren't created by a
creator we evolved into human beings
that would be the biological point of
view all right by the way I'm quoting
from this great book sapiens but I just
think that what's fascinating about the
Declaration of Independence is that that
may be a myth that may be a story we've
all agreed on but it has created certain
truths it's created a great way to live
in comparison to other systems of
government well isn't that religion in
general is a story it's a story and it
has all ours we all value that has truth
to assure right so so truth to it but
don't premises is a lot of them are
based off stories yeah and one of the
truths could be that that when you when
you have a declaration of the heaven
that holds that as an ideal one of the
truths is that that may be more useful
it's certainly more useful in living a
good life than say communism a
dictatorship or a monarchy and stuff
like that so that's an example of where
I think and from this book sapiens but I
I this is I'm kind of extrapolating
we're you know believing in myth
believing in story and agreeing is how
human beings get things done some right
but but it's how it's how societies are
structured general right and you can you
can be structured remember like in
Babylon the idea was that the agreement
was that the king was basically endowed
with you know rights from the creator
and and and there were high-class people
there were these there was it was all a
caste system slaves the hierarchy did
not everybody was created either and
this radical idea that the founding
fathers came more along with probably
first time in history which was that all
men are created equal by their creator
it's fascinating because that is that is
that is seeped into all of our beings
even atheists who don't believe in a
creator and God it is that's the one
thing you don't hear a lot of like even
atheists say they would never say I
you're not equal even though
biologically you are we aren't equal we
all as liberal people we all believe
that everybody has their own in
worth and it says and and you would
never see the humor I'm worth more than
you are exactly and that fascinating and
that's where myth and story has great
value and I would even argue great truth
to offer and so be careful about you
know praying to the God of rationality
saying that there is no God maybe there
isn't God but you benefit every single
day from a system of government that was
formed on the idea that we're all of the
same moral worth which comes from the ID
the Christian notion of God kind of
fascinating
so even atheists benefit from religious
thinking and that's my dropping
knowledge ladies and gentlemen thank you
founding fathers something a BB you have
any dates I'm glad you asked buddy I am
going to be in two places one I'm gonna
be in San Jose the San Jose improv in
two weeks I have sinned yeah it's gonna
be great so I'll be at the San Jose
improv at exactly October 12 13th and
14th
I can't wait we love that place loves
them and then the next weekend I'm gonna
be at the Yuk Yuk's in Calgary which is
another one of my favorite places so
chief at kake.com and then a little
birdie told me your special comes out
tomorrow buddy buddy never grow up
October 3rd and I think you can go on
hulu amazon and itunes yes you can and
i'm gonna post a bunch of other
platforms but major ones I made you
lunch Amazon in iTunes that's right
buddy never grow up I will read it again
was there and the actual visual you're
gonna get the whole you actually not
just the auditory but you ain't no
listener auto no you're gonna see it you
can see it on Hulu Amazon iTunes and any
other platform that you choose boom
October
stand up wise I mean I'm at the Comedy
Store but it's as far as official dates
not till November November third of
Friday I'm at Colusa casino NorCal gets
it what it's about an hour outside sack
sack down
yes I'm like that I'm there and then I
am in Ontario Ontario its Inland Empire
not Canada I'm in Ontario November 30th
antara improv get to youth right now for
Brian and myself TV at kake.com clues a
casino November 3rd that's a Friday
Ontario improv November 30th love it t
fat k calm we got chinder shirts
dropping this week we have dick diver
being restocked we saw that we saw that
hard didn't do he did I had a lot of guy
and in Philly I had a lot of guys with a
steak and a suck I had all those coming
back we got new stuff old stuff it's all
gravy baby counseled rostrum I'll never
grow up this is the fun kid we're out